For this problem, a grocer wants to mix pounds of raisins with pounds of nuts
to get a trail mix. He's wondering how much of each he should use to make the
trail mix. So, we know we're going to need two variables, r will stand for
pounds of raisins he'll use and n will stand for the pounds of nuts he'll use.
The trail mix will contain both the raisins and the nuts. So, if we add up the
pounds of the raisins, and the pounds of the nuts, we'll get our total pounds
of trail mix. I can use these variables to write my first equation. The pounds
of raisins r, plus the pounds of nuts n, should equal 15, our total amount of
trail mix. For the second equation, we know that the cost of raisins plus the
cost of the nuts should be the total cost of the trail mix. Our raisins are
charged at $3.50 per pound, so if I take $3.50 per pound times the number of
pounds of raisins, I'll get my cost of the raisins. The same is true for the
nuts. We have n pounds of nuts times $2.00 per pound. So this is my cost. The
trail mix is going to cost $2.66 per pound. But we need to figure out how much
pounds in total we have of trail mix. If we used r pounds of raisins and n
pounds of nuts, then our total pounds of trail mix would be r plus n. This last
part is probably one of the hardest steps in this problem, but if you remember
that you are making the trail mix from pounds of raisins and pounds of nuts, it
should make sense. I'm going to solve this system using substitution, since I
can easily sub with one of these variables. If I subtract r from both sides,
I'll get n is equal to 15 minus r. Now I can perform substitution. I'll take 15
minus r and plug it in for n in my second equation. I could also take 15 minus
r and plug it in for n right here in the equation. But I already know the value
of r plus n. I know r plus n is equal to 15, so I can replace this entire
parentheses with 15. Replacing this parentheses with 15 will be much simpler
than replacing this n with 15 minus r. Because here we'll get a number instead
of a bunch of variables. Next, I group my like terms together. Then I subtract
30 from both sides to get 1.5r is equal to 9. Finally, we divide by the
coefficient of r to get r is equal to 6. R showed for the number of pounds of
raises we used, so really this is 6 pounds. The pounds of raises and the pounds
of nuts should add up to 15. So, using some mental math, or solving an
equation, we can get n as equal to 9 pounds, the pounds of nuts. As always,
let's go back and make sure these answers make sense. Our pounds of raisins was
6, and our pounds of raisins was 9. So, the grocer had 6 pounds and 9 pounds,
which did indeed total 15 pounds. Next we can replace 6 for r and 9 for n to
determine the cost and make sure that our second equation is true. So, we
replace each of the variables, and then I multiply each of these numbers
together, making sure to add 6 and 9 before multiplying by $2 and 60 cents. So
we have 21 dollars plus 18 dollars equals 39 dollars so yes this equation is
true as well